he's a pro Football Hall of Famer and a
friend of the show and a friend in
general he is none of them how long how
are you how I I'm good good to be home
I am bet it is after a long slog of a
season so what were your impressions of
Super Bowl 54 it's your lasting
impression of that game sir I think
there's there's been a changing of the
guard in terms of you know Patrick
mahomes in the quarterback position and
I think his his ability you know
throughout the course of the playoffs
and that football team's ability to you
know I think coming into the week I
thought you know you can't make the same
kind of mistakes that you've made in the
previous two games in terms of penalties
drop balls turnovers etc and and when
versus this kind of a team I I really
like San Francisco's defense I really
like their run game I think Jimmy when
he is in that play-action pass mode and
you know there's six or seven initially
and protection and he's comfortable and
there's a free runner that's his game
and I think Kansas City showed that you
know throw caution to the wind and you
know forget about clock management
forget about turnovers forget about you
know being down by ten in the fourth
quarter you know with seven minutes left
and you know a guy who had not had
really a good game a great game you know
they all of a sudden put 21 points up
and you know in a flash and and I think
it's a credit to Andy it's credit to the
quarterback and it's particularly a
credit to the defense which I think
stings bagnolo who you know famously was
you know the Giants defense coordinator
when they played the undefeated Patriots
team and I didn't see any way that uh
you know the Giants could beat the
Patriots and you know that improbable
play were Eli suddenly looks like Tyler
Moore
you know we break five tackles and
tosses the ball up to a receiver who
hadn't caught a ball in weeks in
practice and he catches the ball not
only in the biggest moment but catches
it on his head
you know the Super Bowl is it's larger
than life now and you know what the two
weeks leading up to it I think
everything is analyzed regurgitated you
know you can hear 72 different
perspectives because we we live in a day
and age when there's a show on every
five minutes in a different format that
you can overanalyze fun but certainly by
the time the game rolls around I think
the players are ready to go well in
terms of and in terms of the analysis
Howie Long here in the Rich Eisen show
there's there's a ton after it's all
over what do you think Kyle Shannon is
thinking today what do you think's going
through his temples at this very moment
Howie boy oh boy I feel bad for him I
really do you know knowing how to it's
it's making it to the Super Bowl is you
know the equivalent of climbing Mount
Everest and some people falter at
Basecamp one two three when you're in
the Super Bowl and you're seven minutes
away from you know with a ten point lead
and you know you go back to the Patriots
game you know I wouldn't say this was
this to me was not as you know
questionable as you know run the ball
three times versus Patriots and you know
you're you're the Super Bowl champion
and I don't care what the personnel is I
don't care who you have a quarterback I
don't care who you have a wide receiver
and some of that's on the head coach
because the head coach at that point
should have said and you know I've
talked to Jimmy about this
the head coach should have said hey
here's what I want to do I want to run
the ball three times let's get out of
here with a win and get it done now this
was a little bit more complex but I'm
just not a believer in you know when
you're running the ball the way they're
running the ball though it was not you
you take away the Deebo Samuel you know
reverse play and you know then the
number goes way down but still Kansas
City and you know talking to their
players after the game they were really
happy that San Francisco got away from
the run game and what that does is it
puts the onus on Jimmy Garoppolo who you
know could end up being a really you
know great quarterback for them but at
this point he's not the guy if you're
not running the ball extremely well
you're not running play-action pass and
you go back and look at his highlights
throughout the course of the season and
I looked at everything and you know 90%
of it was off play-action pass and
there's usually a free runner and he's
really good at that he missed throws he
missed receivers didn't see them the
throw he missed downfield to Emmanuel
Sanders you know here's a guy that you
know was a great acquisition from a
leadership standpoint it gives them
another receiver when you really think
about it Kansas San Francisco really
doesn't have a true number one Deebo
samuel is is a really impressive player
but he's not your prototypical number
one guy but he's so versatile e so tough
and he's so hard to bring down after the
catch but Emmanuel Sanders was a good
pickup but he's not a guy who can
separate and here was a situation where
he runs through the double coverage and
he's open and that's game set match and
it's a throw that you know you you you
know if you're going to be in that elite
category where you're being paid 30 35
million a year you got to make so do you
think that Shannon is sitting here
thinking if Jimmy G's the
and Lynch is thinking that or or or or
what what was the next moment you know
what they're thinking but I you know I
think it's pretty at this point you know
and Terry and I talked about it a little
bit throughout the course of the week
and you know riding back in that
two-hour drive back down the south beach
from the stadium talked a little bit
about that and you know he likes Jimmy G
and you know and with good reason I mean
you know I we forget how how young years
and how few games he's played but then
you flip it over to the other side and
yeah in a day and age where we have
specialized athletes at the high school
level and even below that where they're
just focusing in on one sport and
they're going to the showcase camps and
you know seven on seven you know passing
camps and that's all they do
Patrick was a three-sport athlete coming
out of high school and he had to get
three scholarship offers coming out of
high school which is to me absurd almost
as absurd as him dropping to where he
dropped in Kansas City trades up and
gets him I I think being a three-sport
athlete as he was and having grown up
around professional sports with his dad
the moments not too big and I think you
see elements of all three of those
sports in his game his ability to you
know extend plays and and essentially be
a point guard on rerouting receivers
that are you know in a complex you know
downfield environment were you know
you've got to anticipate people being
open he's like a point guard and then
you know the middle infielder with off
platform throws at different you know
arm slots that's an in middle infielder
turning - and then his ability to get
from vertical to horizontal really
quickly it's like there are people that
have those elements to their game like a
rustle or calamari but you know he
the fourth I think he runs a for three I
think he ran a for three and that was
that was what I had heard you know
Patrick is not that he's a four seven
guy but he he's so instinctive and he
reads coverages so well and the moments
not too big for him and when you falter
you know you struggle you've thrown two
interceptions and you know it's not your
day to this point and you have the
wherewithal to you know gather yourself
and be up for the moment and he
certainly was and you know that's why he
was the MVP how a long few more minutes
left with him here on the Rich Eisen
show ask the poll question of Howie
because how are you just obviously
opined about how special an athlete
mahomes is he's 24 he's already got a
Super Bowl MVP a league MVP a Super Bowl
championship only human being to
accomplish that before age 25 and Andy
Reid with 200 plus career wins is a
regular season coach just added a Super
Bowl championship and he's just 61 years
old so that's the question of how he
long Chris all right now we which AFC
team most in the way of a potential
Chiefs dynasty here so AFC only Browns
Ravens Texans whatever Tom Brady plays
what do you think Howie um the Tom Brady
question is so complex because if Tom
goes anywhere you know I think he was he
really didn't have the pieces around him
to play and at a high level and whether
they do that or you know Harry kind of
bounces back and you know Edelman is
back from surgery and you know all those
things and last year was Devlin and
Gronk as a blockers and play-action pass
that's a lot to do I would say Baltimore
I think Baltimore is is a really really
physical tough football team that
unfortunately ran into a team that you
know was ready for the moment and right
for the to match them physically
particularly in their defensive front
you know and I think about the fourth
down plays and I think about you know
their ability to shut that down and you
know they made enough plays and I think
they're kind of a reflection of their
coach and they'll be better too
yeah I think they will be also and I I I
look forward to seeing Marv Jackson and
and my homes maybe battling it out and I
do I really do
I think their coach is terrific he won't
coach of the year for a reason I'm still
very high in Lamar Jackson even though a
lot of people think that he might not be
a so-called big game guy he certainly
looked pretty darn good against the New
England Patriots in the regular season
he doesn't want to playoff game yet I
think he's got a big big game they just
look at higher offense was really you
know just built around him and my only
question with him is inevitably they
will get you it's just the way it is
you mean defense where you run the ball
the more you expose yourself you know
there are big physical fast people who
you know given the right opportunity or
the wrong you know spot for him could
deliver the kind of blow that you know
could in in some way impair is his
career that's the concern you know you
certainly would like to see him being
more judicial in terms of getting down
you know we talked about the kid in
Arizona for example I mean how quickly
does he get down how quickly does
Russell get down and and knowing when to
get down and fight another play and I
think that's something he needs to you
know kind of develop and evolve and I
think he will I do too
well how we I appreciate you coming on
before I let you go you know other than
doing TV it's very rare where I could
come up with an instance where you know
what I kind of feel like how I long
right now you know I haven't acted and
say action films I haven't done pretty
much
much of your resume but yesterday Howie
my 11 year old son Xander in his fifth
grade B basketball team game scored his
first two career points and I know what
you must have felt like when your son
won the Super Bowl
Howie you know I I it's interesting the
congratulations thank you sir
thank you it's so interesting because I
tell people this and I I did an
appearance with Kyle down in Miami and
you know I'd never done anything with
him before and yeah you know I was
really kind of blown away it's like you
know very you know thought-provoking guy
and interesting and I think he was on
ESPN Chicago today and he ho co-hosted
for the day and listening to him and I
was just blown away but what people
don't understand is the feeling you had
at that game it's the same feeling I had
at you know whether it's Kyle being
successful how he or Chris and you know
the two big games was Philadelphia was
New England it's just it's it's being
covered by you know millions of people
on TV it's the same exact feeling you
have in Pop Warner or youth basketball
or anything I tell folks that and they
find that hard to believe but I really
believe that and it's a great feeling
and you're happy for your your your kids
and congratulations Thank You Holly when
when his team had only had four points
in the first quarter and then only four
points entering the fourth quarter I'm
glad I did not
I'm glad I did not have 22
high-definition cameras showing off my
facial expression to millions of people
because the country and then rich you
know hopefully at some point you know he
advances and you know has an opportunity
to play wherever we're doing anything
like that you're gonna have to deal with
people being critical of your son and
and then it becomes like a you know I
want it I want your address and I want
to come to your house and I want to
pummel you how you feel about people
that are being critical
my gosh how is Kyle before I let you go
is he doing alright see father great
down to about 290 okay he looks great he
sounds great
he did a lot of things with media down
there and made a couple of appearances
and I think he had a really good week
for him and then Chris and him did his
podcast together down there which was
really cool to see those two you know
listen when you got three sons you know
you'd go to the emergency room a lot and
they beat each other up and it's been
it's a problem but you know to see those
two you know has grown up being civil
and you know somewhat entertaining is
kind of cool that's good so are you how
he thanks for the call we'll chat soon
great season on Fox hey partner thank
you brother
thank you that's how he longed right
here for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app